like in 2008 was the first time my
mother voted on but I was lunder age and
then she said oh I voted for McCain but
I knew Obama would win anyway and I'm
like what would have happened if McCain
had one mother what then
I was born in Hungary I am from Mexico
somebody split to see I am originally
from the Philippines my name is Ana
Paula Delia and I'm from Mexico City
Mexico I am originally from the
Philippines
I became a citizen in April of 2012 I've
lived in the United States since 1990
and I only became a citizen and actually
they shortly before the election in 2011
and I became a citizen last March it
means a lot to be little for me to be
able to exercise my vote and then go and
tell people to actually do it because
it's it's so important so critical
especially this year
why I'm just jealous for me it honestly
took 27 years until I was able to vote
so I had nine years
I just watched people vote or not vote
people who have had the privilege to you
know be able to vote their entire life
and then choose not to is a little
frustrating for me you shouldn't take
your voting rights through granted you
should really just do it it's hard to
you know really make an informed
decision but I think the more education
that we have around voting and you know
just civic duty the more that we will be
able to make decisions that we won't
wake up the next morning and be like
what the hell did I just do I know it's
not a fun election you may love or not
love either candidate but you just still
vote because you can't
I'm part of this system I am you know
kind of like working towards you know
towards addressing you know problems and
issues that we have